how to find out what customers want I
got a great question from our YouTube
viewers rob el roble love you guys wrote
in the say i was wondering as an
entrepreneur how I might be able to find
out customer demands for specific
products this is a great question this
is really important for you to do as an
entrepreneur and something that I made a
mistake of in my early business and it
nearly killed my company I was building
a software company and the most advanced
feature in it was something that our
customers didn't actually care about my
partners were our customer base as well
and they love this feature and a few of
our customers love this feature but most
of our customers didn't care about it so
we spent all this time and effort
creating this the software tool where
one of the main features was useless to
a lot of people now luckily we had
enough other great features that people
would still want to buy it but it's so
important to get your customers involved
in the decision making process and have
them help you guide your process so
every new software launch we had
afterwards we involve their customers we
ask them what they want and we ask them
how they're using it and it helped our
company grow so if your first study now
how do you go out and you get customers
involved you have to start talking to
people you can do a little bit online
you can start researching you can look
at forms you can look at blogs you can
look at amazon and look at what people
are talking about the products in your
industry but you have to go out and
start talking to people what i would do
is try to find convention trade shows
meetup groups people who are actually
their potential customers you're not
talking about what you can do for them
you're just asking about their problems
you're asking about how they use certain
types of products or services you're
asking about their pain points you're
looking for a hole right you're looking
for an opportunity to become in ideal
you get to the point where you can work
with a client you can work with a
customer even if it's free to get
started just to get some feedback you
want people to give you feedback and say
hey that's really good this is really
helpful or it's not or you need to
change these 10 things to make it work
but you need to start
chin out and getting involved in the
groups that are in your community where
your customers are hanging out okay the
later step is going to be you you know
being a speaker being an expert being an
authority being the one that people are
interviewed but you got to start
somewhere right now it's just going out
and talking to people and again we're
not selling anything yet all you want to
do is get a sense of what their problems
are and how you might be able to make
something that helps them so go online
right now and set researching what kind
of events are coming up in your
community where your customers are going
to be at and go hang out with them go be
there sitting on the sessions meet them
at the meetup groups go to the seminars
go to the workshops whatever it is start
talking to them to get feedback it's the
most valuable advice you're going to get
when you're starting the company to get
specific feedback from your customers
believe those you watching like the
video thumbs up below let me know what
you think leave a comment ask a question
below and you want to see more videos
like this click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much and I'll
see you soon